une bonne nouvelle j'ai appelé le coût
direct des grands ils vont te faire
l'attribution du logement
ce sera il encore fin du calvaire pour
audrey lecouffe cette jeune étudiante en
master 2 originaire de lille va enfin
pouvoir poser ses valises et ses livres
dans la résidence rené cassin
d'elancourt
elle était en recherche active d'un
logement étudiant depuis fin août à
quelques jours de la reprise des cours
audrey a dû attendre deux semaines avant
d'avoir deux propositions pendant quinze
jours c'était c'était moi ma voiture et
mon sac quoi honnêtement c'était jeu
réservé à la dernière minute un hôtel à
droite à gauche
je regarde à combien de kilomètres il
est de la fac je regarde où est ce que
je vais pouvoir me garer faire ceci cela
une recherche de dernière minute risqué
selon le responsable du service logement
il est conseillé de monter son dossier
avant les vacances estivales
et lorsque la recherche de logement
commence vers fin routes au mois de
septembre
la plupart des logements sont attribués
les offres il ya très peu d'offres est
généralement les offres qui restent sont
les plus élevés pour le crous du site
vers saint-quentin qui gère neuf
résidences universitaires et 1200
logements entre saint cloud il encourt
la procédure a été respectée
le risque zéro n'existe pas cependant on
a un taux de satisfaction que très élevé
et là en l'occurrence n'y a pas eu de
dysfonctionnement ya une demande tardive
on était particulièrement réactif c'est
qu'elle était la procédure
elles s'étaient d'abord adressés à nos
partenaires de l'université versailles
saint quentin qui nous ont transmis le
dossier pour plus de réactivité
la directrice des résidences
universitaires est allée elle-même
portel dossier aux services centraux
le 14 septembre maudret emménagent
enfants dans son nouvel appartement à
elancourt un studio de 20 m² loués 377
euros sans avoir déduit les aides
personnalisées au logement c'est les
aléas en fait c'est malheureusement si
on n'est pas prêt à vivre ça à notre âge
on n'est pas prêt avec plein de choses
par la suite quoi ça m'a plus perturbée
au niveau du budget et ça c'est sûr
heureusement mes parents sont là
d'ailleurs même si j'ai souvent eu des
jobs pour compenser quoi audrey va
maintenant se concentrer sur ses études
elle devrait rester dans son logement
étudiant à elancourt jusqu'au mois de
janvier et la fin de son diplôme